Showtime at Mesa elephant camp twice a
day the elephants entertain visitors
with their skills
everything looks playful but tricks like
this are only possible after long
training explains one of the camp
managers if you would like to let your
children know English you should talk
English to them since they were young
right same thing with Elif if you would
like to let them obey you are listed on
you you teach them thing they were young
for centuries
elephants in Southeast Asia were used
for transport in the timber industry
until logging was banned in the region
thirty years ago with thousands of
captive elephants out of work their
owners turned to tourism elephant
tourism is now a lucrative business but
one that's lightly regulated Nina Othman
brass is a biologist she advises camps
on how to ensure that entertaining
tourists isn't detrimental to elephant
well-being good welfare can easily be
done in a writing camp if you provide
the elephant with shade enough food
enough water enough rest and and
otherwise free from discomfort also the
biologist is pleased with the camp's
general conditions for the elephants
seem to be in good shape she says but
she admits that she often runs into
secrecy just like today
when asked about the specific methods of
training young elephants the camp
veterinarian becomes rather tight-lipped
and who day
on the Internet it's possible to find
videos of a torturous ritual designed to
break an elephant's spirit the method
has been used for centuries it's a
brutal training process that can go on
for weeks
only when the elephant stops resisting
is it released from its agony
animal rights groups are calling for a
boycott of elephant camps they're
convinced interactions like these are
only possible once an elephant has been
broken
many Western travel companies have
stopped offering this kind of tourism
but with growing numbers of Chinese
visitors business is thriving
Nina Othman brusque thinks an effective
boycott would do more harm than good
coming into the camp the elephant will
still be here but it will just have very
very poor conditions elephant tourism is
sold as cute harmless fun but once you
look a bit closer a darker picture
starts to emerge